et et 1961 à paris c'est l'inauguration
en grande pompe du premier fast food de
france le wimpy en présence de vedettes
comme les frères jacques
un véritable événement c'est la première
fois que les français découvrent le
hamburger imposer le fast food au pays
de la gastronomie
la tâche fut difficile derrière ce pari
fou se cache un businessman redoutable
jacques borel
ap archétype de l'homme pressé
industriel exubérant qui aiment sifflé
en travaillant est ce que jacques borel
m le morceau de steak haché entre deux
morceaux de pain franchement quand j'ai
malheureusement pour moi j'ai pas le
temps de le prendre parce que la plupart
du temps tout comme les cordonniers je
suis mal chaussés j'ai pas le temps de
déjeuner chaque bord elle n'a pas le
temps
pionnier de la restauration collective
des restaurants d'autoroute inventeur du
ticket resto et père du fast food en
france
l'homme d'affaires agace d'abord les
cantines ensuite la cuisine britannique
s'était beaucoup pour les puristes de la
gastronomie
ils font d'abord et leur bête noire son
nom devient synonyme de malbouffe mais
la critique n'est pas un problème pour
le napoléon du prêt-à-manger tant que
c'est bon pour le business
à défaut d'être bon dans l'assiette
parce que vous savez la pire des choses
dans la vie ce qu'on ne parle pas de
vaud c'est la pire de toutes
que nous soyons très critique est très
content revers en fait beau rêve ça ne
vous y trompez pas il ne laisse pas
insensible on adore ou on déteste
on n'est pas au mieux
vivante trop avant gardiste la chaîne de
fast-food wimpy n'a pas le succès
escompté et commencent à disparaître à
la fin des années 60 le hamburger
c'était trop pour les français pourtant
quelques années plus tard on m'a mis
deux manches il me fait douter de
préférence et les jeunes qui viennent en
complément du que je tue pas moi le
fast-food remet le couvert et devient au
début des années 80 un véritable
phénomène de société une tendance
amplifiée par l'arrivée officielle du
géant américain mcdonald's en 1979
que valent les hamburgers que l'on mange
en quelques minutes assis ou bien debout
devant une petite desserte jusqu'au plus
haut niveau de l'état on s'interroge
je trouve que c'est le c'est l'anti
nourriture c'est l'anti art de
s'assembler autour d'une table quoi
qu'on en pense
aujourd'hui le fast food s'est imposée
et avec lui le hamburger on en avale ray
en france plus de 4 millions par jour
mieux le petit pain rond s'est détachée
de son image de malbouffe et se retrouve
au menu des meilleurs restaurants et
jacques borel dans tout ça il était trop
en avance sur son temps c'est le
problème avec les hommes pressés
[Musique]